[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance as we continue down the path
that to again steal from Churchill may
not be the beginning of the end but is
certainly the end of the beginning this
vital sidebar question is it also the
end of whatever control of himself that
Donald Trump has is it also the end of
his for want of a more precise term
sanity and what does that mean about
what he does next obviously he could try
to fire Bob Muller there are three huge
roadblocks by law only the Attorney
General can remove the special counsel
attorney General Sessions has recused
himself from the Russia case so either
you'd have to get Deputy Attorney
General Rosen Stein to fire Muller or
somebody below him to do it or you fire
sessions and put in a new Attorney
General to fire Muller in short it all
becomes something worse than Nixon's
Saturday night massacre second also by
law the special counsel can be removed
only for quote misconduct dereliction of
duty incapacity conflict of interest or
for other good cause including violation
of departmental policies and a quote
specific reason must be given and there
is ample evidence that Muller could go
to court sue the Attorney General could
be reinstated by a judge and there's
what senator Graham the Republican of
South Carolina said in July any effort
to go after Muller could be the
beginning of the end of the Trump
presidency
unless Muller did something wrong he
also said he was introducing legislation
to make it illegal to fire a special
counsel without judicial review but this
is less about the practicalities of
Muller and more about the practicalities
of Trump if there are any practicalities
even before the Muller News even as the
right-wing propaganda machine convinced
its own side that it repelled the
invasion and it won the war on d-day
even after the corker and flake and
McCain repudiation --zz Tom Coburn the
former Oklahoma senator matter-of-factly
told the New York Times that Trump would
not be abandoned by his supporters
because he had fulfilled so many of
their most ardent desires but Coburn had
started that statement with what seemed
like almost a throwaway line
that is in fact mightily important quote
we have a leader who has a personality
disorder so what you say some
Republicans do acknowledge this obvious
thing
and Rollins told me last year that I was
right and Trump is crazy
McCain flake corker a handful of others
have said similar things so Coburn says
Trump has a personality disorder so what
Tom Coburn is a medical doctor maternal
and family practice obstetrics mostly
and dealing with new mothers who as we
know are often subject to a gauntlet of
postpartum psychological and emotional
issues dr. Tom Coburn is not guessing
here it seems as if he's diagnosing then
David Brooks the conservative columnist
of the New York Times wrote another one
of his patented I'm shocked shocked to
find that gambling is going on in here
pieces Al biet with one twist the
Republican senators he wrote greeted
Trump on Capitol Hill and saw a
president so repetitive and rambling
some thought he might be suffering from
early Alzheimer's well that's as good an
amateur diagnosis as any layman has yet
produced these words salad statements
Trump makes in which he seems to be
about to make a point but never quite
gets there and more accurately seems to
wind up evoking a free-form word
association screening test that could
easily be the result of anything on the
spectrum of diseases which deteriorate
the brain we know democratic office
holders are finally waking to Trump's
craziness being literal not figurative a
psychiatry professor at Yale says she's
been contacted by half a dozen senators
and representatives who are trying to
figure this out there's a duty to warn
group of mental health professionals
there's a book no wait there's two books
I forgot mine and most importantly there
is good old-fashioned public opinion two
months ago
Fox News did an actual poll asking
registered voters how well do you think
each of the following words or phrases
describe Donald Trump when the word they
were asked about was unstable these were
the results 16% said the word on stage
describes Trump somewhat well 11% said
the word unstable describes Trump very
well 33% said the word unstable
describes Trump extremely well that's
60% who think he's at least somewhat
unstable and that's not just a poll of
Democrats and retiring Republican
senators and you and me and that's two
months ago that's before Houston and
Puerto Rico and him calling an American
athlete a son of a [ __ ] and the pense
Trump national anthem stunts and quote
warmest condolences for Las Vegas and
the desperate crazy do something tweet
from last Sunday morning we have all
encountered somebody who is let's call
it impaired not fully connected to the
reality around them every once in a
while we see them in crisis and their
reactions run the gamut some break
completely and withdraw some overreact
but it seems to me and this is only
anecdotally that some slow majority do
not recognize the danger they are in in
time so we may hope that as the
indictment process unfolds Trump belongs
to the latter group remember that as
late as last month one of his attorneys
was telling him that if he cooperated
with Robert Muller he would ultimately
get what he wanted public vindication
about Russia
his attorney Ty Cobb insisted even
Sunday afternoon the Trump is still
fully cooperating with the special
counsel and you and I may disagree with
what's wrong with him and what he would
do if he truly realized the net is
tightening around him but we can be
certain of this if you told Donald Trump
that the indictments are actually
happening and everybody he knows his
advisers his ex advisors his eldest son
his son-in-law would be indicted and
convicted and imprisoned but he himself
would not be he would simply smile that
megalomaniac smile of his and grab a new
bag of Doritos resist remove peace the
book of these commentaries Trump is
effing crazy is now available without a
referral from a mental health
professional or he can just wait for the
premiere of the CBS Evening how unstable
is
News or something